muy buenas tardes pues el día después de
verdad es que bastante situación aquí
está esa él hace de manera más jugarse
de sven que justamente de gracia esa fue
toda la junta directiva del partido la
república en marcha que se reunió esta
mañana para ver qué es el paso a seguir
vimos a varias personas del gobierno
salen de aquí por una parte william un
ministro de producto en bienes
blanqueada el ministro de educación así
como getafe quien es el presidente de la
asamblea nacional y hacia gonzález mundo
pues cuál es la consigna que se les ha
dado para esta segunda vuelta y
simplemente dijo ir al terreno y al
terreno y al terreno lo cierto es que lo
que también hace exclusivo a través
quizás aclarar algunos puntos es sobre
todo para poder convencer a ese
electorado de izquierda es el electorado
que votó por
irse
y mientras tanto que se me bajó no ha
perdido el tiempo l se encuentra en el
norte del país
visitando como candidatos son las
tierras de marina de penes esta región
del norte del norte de allí que siempre
votan por la extrema derecha y él toda
esta mañana y todo este día de hoy va a
estar justamente allí en de campaña dije
esta vez pues a la idea no es perder
tiempo como quizás ocurrió hace cinco
años sin que esa idea es de una vez
atacar allí donde necesita también ganar
voces de parte de los electores de la
ultraderecha